okay four people joining this livestream
we are talking about image and video
functionality for 12.1 okay starting off
dollar image resolution why is that a
well-defined thing what actually is it
this is to tackle the high VP I wasn't
working here
it's okay there were a lot of conflicts
in the past week it's we are working on
sorting through all of the conflicts
it's possible some things are not in the
builds but it should be documented in
CPS this is to tackle the high DPI
displays and rasterization in order to
have an image resolution correctly
working on different resolution displays
we are updating rasterize to a good
extent and i think this is gonna be a
good addition to all of that to query
for the resolution that is current on
better what does it mean though I mean
so rasterize would take something okay
so you're going to explain what where is
the new stuff and rasterize there is
nothing there's nothing new in in the
page there's gonna be we are finding a
lot of bugs as well or behaviors that
needs to be corrected or rather be
corrected but the thing that the general
idea is that you're creating a graphics
of a disk and it displays as large as
you see it on a screen on a high DPI
you've ends up using twice as many pixel
pixels in both directions to display
there as because it is so if you
rasterize it you presumably want it to
be the new image dimensions rather than
the old image dimension are you saying
rasterize is gonna generate files that
are four times bigger on high DPI I mean
to generate expressions that are four
times bigger yeah well that's that's
what it's using on the monitor and it
would be otherwise it would if you
rasterize an expression on a smaller
resolution using using a smaller
resolution it's gonna all of a sudden
look smaller as well
so it's not gonna look like what you're
seeing on this well so it would be
alright hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold on
that's because our image object doesn't
record the information on what the DPI
is right because it could perfectly well
you know resample itself I mean any
image has an image where actually I'm
now confused image has an image size
right it also has an image resolution
okay what does the image resolution mean
so if it's a so if you have a 72 bytes
if you have 144 by 144 pixel image and
it's a 72 dpi screen it obviously the
size of it the display size of it is
going to be half the size of if it's
used if twice as large that it's being
displayed on a 144 DPI screen I
understand I understand but so you're
saying but if I set image size image
size is a number of pixels right no
that's the display size raster size for
rasterize we also have the raster size
option okay but but image size is just a
display size I know that but it's a
display size in units of pixels in
printers points so that's basically
raster size an image resolution we
combine well your your audio keeps on
dropping out and a kind of annoying way
Sharlee fix that it'd be good but I mean
it's an electronic drop out it's not an
audio drop out um okay so let me
understand this then so Aminta size
purports to be an absolute size on the
screen so you're telling me if I say you
know graphics of disk
image size arrow 72 times five okay
you're telling me that if I put took out
a ruler which I will now do and put it
on my screen which you will not be able
to see because that's not the way screen
sharing works in modern and current
times except I don't seem to have a
ruler because it's not I do have a ruler
look at that it's right at the back of
my collection of stuff here okay let me
get that out and measure it on my screen
hold on one second no it's about 4.2
inches across so what happened here and
also my my notebook is that magnified by
125 percent so 90 vacation clearly
doesn't care about that for image size
right going to be roughly two and a half
now that's so larger probably that's
three point that's about 3.2 inches okay
so what's going on that's because the
faking of dpi is that correct
this is the combination of three is also
it's so very confusing okay it's very
confusing this isn't right
and also as someone's pointing out on
our live stream though the term
resolution which has become used for
monitors is of course not the original
optical meaning of resolution okay so
let's just understand what rasterize
wants to do now so rasterize should take
I mean if I give an expression I mean
let's just understand the the contract
to rasterize okay so I reckon what its
contract should be is if I take an
expression
and it would be rendered with a certain
number of pixels in a notebook right now
then rasterize should have the same
number of pixels in it okay but let me
give you an immediate counter example to
that theory okay
let's imagine that I have the notebook
at 200% it is the case that if I say
style of you know capital a I don't know
50 or something here a hundred that will
render that character at UM much higher
resolution then you see what I'm saying
right yep and I don't know what happens
here does that does the same thing
happen for Roger maybe you can say
something if I do this and I were to
look microscopically this thing is
actually rendering at the 200%
resolution correct
it's got oh because you have 200% mm-hmm
I I'm not entirely sure I believe so I
mean I hope so
okay well we can
that for sure so let's do the following
thing let's say um okay so let's take
that and we could screen capture that
just little tippy tip there we could
paste that in oh gosh
we've still got that bug unbelievable
still got that bug can we make sure that
gets reira ported yet again this thing
about losing focus I thought John said
you'd fix that for you understand about
is somebody Elizabeth is here right okay
so the the bug you understand is that if
I do screen capture here and I try to
paste in at the same notebook if the
paste just doesn't work yes I've to
paste into a different notebook and then
paste it back into the snow book and
then it works fine okay so now if I go
in here and I look at that tippy tip
right see what I see okay now let's go
down I'm going to demonstrate a bit of a
horror here because if I go down here to
100% I recompute I'm the hypothesis I'm
not even sure it's correct but I
recompute that now if I magnify this is
it re-rendering it is rerender isn't it
yeah it is rerun during as I change the
size I'm sorry this is yeah but this is
still all vector graphic I understand
that I understand the question of what
resolution when you say rasterize at
what resolution pasteurize that's what
that's what this is addressing take this
simpler example rasterizing X plus y
yeah cuz then I think for something like
that you're gonna see the blurriness or
the difference between high DPI
rasterization and well okay so you're
saying if I say rasterize and then I
just say something like hello yeah well
okay so now that is that okay so that's
a 100% and that's a big mess okay so
let's try
I I claim this is not going to affect it
if I go to 200% and I redo that
rasterization nothing will change right
correct
even though well actually it turns out
we're wrong
maybe we're not wrong no I think they're
the same yeah rasterize computes this
bounding box ice or as the point I'm
making is at 200% the font if I were to
type it in the notebook the as if
notebook test fails because that font is
rendered at a higher resolution than
visit 100% pressure so let's understand
what the rules I mean we need to write
down what the rules actually are so the
thing is going to a notebook at 100%
magnification on the screen that you are
currently on true or not true I I think
right but I was never or Bieber never
taking into account magnification so far
[Music]
rasterizing into graphics to raster we
want to consider that no I don't think
but just for comparison do ever Astor
eyes with in which resolution step 244
for that hello example and then don't
magnify just just do a pure comparison
between the two okay know what you want
me to do well just compare that with I
know this is what I think this is what
we are aiming to get by default on high
DPI that's the minimum I'll change that
is necessary to at least try to get a
raster that is similar to let me show
you a typical demo slow and maybe we can
speed this up if I do this okay that is
really a bit abominably slow so I'm
saying what do you know why remember
there's a startup problem with rasterize
I don't rasterizes split between care in
the land fronting and we are
coordinating with John for the content
part of it
we just very recently to custody for
looking into the kernel part of
rasterize and this update is the first
updates are making it
okay so I'm gonna tell you I think you
should check on on why that's slow okay
cuz there may be some startup time that
could be saved there okay okay but so
hmm I'm trying to understand here the
results that you will get for the kernel
function rasterize depend on the
resolution of the screen that you happen
to be running on is that correct okay I
have two monitors one is a 4k monitor
one's not a 4k monitor and I were to run
this in the kernel which screen will it
pick I would expect the one that
notebook is in but assume there is no
notebook assume that I'm running this in
a well I mean you know now let me play
the cloud evaluate case now we'll play
the Wolfram script case well I guess in
that case karen dr default is 72 I guess
we could keep it as that or we could say
the world has move on to a higher dpi
and we could just change the defaults
instead of changing the default 144 yeah
I think we should explore that
possibility um if it doesn't know
anything that's what we do right and
what it's honestly I'm a little bit
scared about it it thinking it knows
something and just getting it wrong and
the honestly I think the other scary
part might be that we are gonna be
getting the different size rasters
depending on the platform and screen as
you say and I don't know what workflows
are gonna be broken or become difficult
with that change but if you are sitting
at one monitor right now we get the same
or do we do not get the same it's big
it's a fixed 72 so regardless of we do
know we do not want to mess with it we
do not want to make it depend on what
what screen you happen to be setting at
but
should we just change it to change the
default to 144 that's what I think yes I
think we should ask around to see what
people think I know that's going to
affect the wolf now for stuff it's gonna
affect a bunch of things all right I
feel more comfortable with that setting
as well yes
okay all right we are still we are still
debating some cases with John because I
think there are more cases that are
happening rasterization is happening for
the front-end workflows I think he knows
more about those when it comes to us
it's mostly rasterizing graphics for
working with some image which we have
some image dimensions for that matter
but then I think it should be documented
to be 144 and not automatic and then the
automatic could be used to adapt to your
screen that's fine I think that's
reasonable um okay so there various
comments on the live stream how they're
interesting Bryan is asking is there a
method for setting the DPI of screen
resolution or notebook so all subsequent
graphics primitives use that value
instead of the screen characteristics
this will enable making frames for
videos I don't think you should rely on
the I mean unless you're doing a screen
capture from your screen I think in
terms of making videos um I think you
should be using one of these internal
rasterization things that is not based
on what you happen to see on the screen
so this image resolution thing I don't
really believe in it because I mean it's
like it's like asking what's your screen
size I'm saying I do I think it's just a
mess I mean like I have three monitors
and they have different resolutions what
are you gonna say I mean we've got that
for example and if I look at
to look at and I want to look at system
information here presumably um if I ask
for oh great
it just crashed okay something to report
Pradesh build I I typed system
information that crashed got it
Elizabeth got it thank you
it's now crashing repeatedly so hold on
let me just I'm just going to just try
just so I understand ah what am i typing
system information I'm just doing this
in the current shipping version just to
make my point devices okay so it's
pretty complicated there's our there's
our map you know I've got two screens
um screen one screen to blah blah blah
it's complicated right just saying
there's a resolution I don't think we'll
it cuts it right yeah potentially we can
think about having its default
rasterization resolution or something
like that as Brian was saying on the
live stream yeah so a dollar default
resolution I think that's a good idea
but I mean that that is what is that
that's I mean okay so what is the
setting in rasterize that determines its
image resolution for rasterize right
correct it's it's we have we have a
combination of the three options right
image size raster size image resolution
the three of them what else is image
resolution used for
I believe it's also an option for
graphics right which just stays explore
it's for export
oh you're right so I mean it would be
natural for dollar image resolution to
be the default image resolution to use
for the default setting for image
resolution which is not saying it's not
making any claim about what the actual
physical Hardware you're using it has or
anything like that it's just um you know
the default image resolution and that
does seem to me to make sense so I think
would satisfy what Brian is looking for
here and by the way sander is pointing
out that rasterize should be sped up a
lot he's right it's really really really
slow and I really think you should have
somebody look at that because I think
that could um help a lot of things that
we could really speed that up and I
don't know exactly why it's slow um okay
all right I think then dollar in this
resolution it's not going to go and the
default for rasterize um the so the
default
a set is image resolution arrow 144 and
you're gonna check whether how that
affects people and automatic for a
notebook could be made to be the
resolution that would be on the screen
that would be rendered with that okay
that makes sense
yep I'm not totally certain we want that
but I think and unfortunately in terms
of existing code that could lead to
weird behavior I mean it's possible I
totally agree yeah we'll have to take a
lot of things before it's possible that
what we should do is leave automatic to
be 72 and not undie documented for now
and expect that in time that will change
I see okay so the old default is gonna
say or the old setting explicit setting
of automatic behaves like before but but
we wanted that to stay that default as
well or default one for you I think it
should change the 144 okay okay Roger
remind me in um graph property value is
being updated to be what now a notation
value I think okay and and the property
wrapper itself is being updated to be
what a notation okay so what is
annotation rules here in image that's
the option yeah that's the option for
audio we introduced it in 12 okay that
was the thing that we agreed would be
the general mechanism for all of the
stuff as annotation rules correct yes
nice okay okay so
in which annotate is doing the name
value kind of thing is there a graph
annotate or how does that work Roger and
now you use no these are special just
because they it's not entirely clear yet
but we think that these are there
because we think that they're convenient
ways to automatically do it using some
of their measurement and other things
measurement functions like the things in
that future stuff cell faces contents
barcodes and so forth so we'll have
named annotations image measurements and
all your measurements I understand so
the name but so how will that work in
this in this design look at audio
annotate image or annotate is gonna
mimic that there gonna be some there is
a arbitrary function case where the
second or where the spec would be any
function at like all your measurements
image measurements as Roger is saying
but they're also going to be a few named
ones like audible inaudible in all you
annotate and and probably a list of
those for image ability yeah now some
prop include but where the property is
being put in I don't see that in the
study in this in this documentation
that's oh no that's the second argument
as a whole as to see the first usage all
you annotate audio come up row ok but
then but that's not what you're
documenting there but so if I were to
say something like I'm gonna try and
type in this version because otherwise
I'm gonna hit the autocomplete file for
image is another important thing and
possibly for audio too but for image to
interactively annotate is not
unimportant at all and so I think that
mean it means that you bring up an
editor where you can annotate the image
you know like okay you do you know so
that will come in those attached
you know the attached cell Angela
yeah so for instance we're going to be
able to say image annotate image comma
faces by the way is that something known
- that - Noah who's working on attach
cells for editing and so on probably
worth pointing out okay so then if you
say this then what's the what should
come back is that is that then the
facial features of image etc etc etc I
guess that's up for discussion it could
just annotate a bunch of rectangles with
the named faces or face which is no
properties or we could have properties
and I think I don't know I don't have a
good proposal we do have this arbitrary
function where you can say whether you
just want find faces or you want facial
features with a whole bunch of
properties or we could introduce a whole
bunch of named ones that says how
they'll how much how much detail you
want to annotate for each of the
detections right I think you're gonna
want named things because I think people
are gonna want well I'm not sure I'm not
sure um okay let me just just don't want
to get into the situation that we have
faces with ages faces with gender faces
with emotion faces with ages and gender
you know it's just gonna become endless
stead of settings that we wanna have
okay look I'm not sure okay let's let's
skip ahead here a little bit so um I
mention annotation look up what is that
going to do it's gone
it's gonna find annotations that are
stored in the image but in addition to
that we have a formatter where we can
say something to each other discovered
annotations and then reduce them to
something for instance get the total
they count I understand why this isn't a
more generic annotation lookup which
applies to all objects with annotation
rules I think eventually we can make it
a general lookup function but we're not
certain it's gonna work for all the
objects that are going to contain
annotations down the road so it might be
safer to just introduce we do have audio
annotation lookup maybe let's try with
this as well as a separate function if
we think it's safe and and we don't have
any graph annotation look up yet but if
we play with that and we think we can
merge them I think it would be fine to
have an annotation lookup function
eventually okay but now what were you
saying about what to do with the
annotations
so you're saying here I get an
annotation we have a dummy example as
the first example this is just a
constant image with two disks saved as
annotations okay named foo so you can
ask for all of them you can ask for food
where you get the lists of two regions
with some bad news
then you can format each one of those
annotations with that formatter
function which formatting function the
slot region and percent is the formatter
for it's it it's very similarly like
group boy at this point like what like
group by the function group so you
format everything that comes back and
then their third argument is a reducer
function they say I get all of the
regions
I can regen measure all of those regions
and I get it I go that's kind of nice
I'm not sure I would guess that you
could do that from okay
ok we got a couple of points on the live
stream here I want to respond to um
Brian is saying there should be a
variable that contains the current
screen resolution and what automatic
would select yeah the current screen
resolution is available from current
image a cut current value right current
value of screen rectangle I think why
isn't that also completing that is very
suspicious okay
it's issue for Elizabeth that should
autocomplete current value in ads should
autocomplete but but that's my screen
resolution um screen and I don't know
whether there's a current I don't even
know what that means I don't know what I
guess that's the screen I'm currently on
okay I don't know how this works but but
that's a yeah there we go there it is um
and those are that that resolution is
fake presumably I think that's the old
problem that OSS didn't properly track
it I don't know if it's fake I mean
that's where it's fake um well Levi
asked us repeatedly and it's always come
back to be turned out to be fake because
Microsoft didn't properly transition and
I'm not sure Apple did either so in
other words you can't trust him
let's find out and let's see whether
there's a different current value that
we could have for you know physical
screen resolution for example would be a
possible name for it if there is you
know if there's a difference there okay
um so okay look
let's do a quick scan down the other
things you have here because we're
clearly not gonna get through everything
I know Roger you and I I have two more
design reviews stacked back-to-back here
um so I want to say that first of all
that radial basis nonlinear transform
there should have been moved out so it's
it's more an open-ended discussion for
what what roughly is it it's the
question first of all well the nonlinear
transformation function is whether we
should have a system-wide container that
we can start building up and fill out so
it's more demand discussion oriented
what should live in such a thing and
what services it would do it's not I
don't feel it's finished to deploy in
other words this is kind of the analog
of interpolating function but for some
kind of transformation type thing yeah
interesting I mean but good but we are
not entirely sure what properties it
should have and the scope of it so
that's what I'm saying it feels not yeah
I agree
okay um okay by the way Ben on the live
stream is asking is there a target
release date for 12.1 will it be ready
ahead of the technology conference we
hope it will be ready around that time a
good solid beta but there's already a
beta program that's already started up
I'm not at the frontlines of that um Ali
is asking can users use the mass
creation toolbar to annotate arbitrary
regions in an image I believe that's the
intent right yes how will that work
what will the interface be in between
the UI of annotating with the mask and
the the named annotation in other words
will that will that UI provide the
possibility for you to enter a name for
example sir we haven't we haven't built
it yet we've built various prototypes
and sometimes you want cross marks that
the targets the center of cells or
something like that sometimes you want
rectangle you want to capture the shape
of something so I think we need we got
to go down the path of what all those
you know obvious cases are okay I I
recommend that you interact with that
NOAA lad who's working on the on the
graphics tool
because I think of course he has good
things to say about this ok let's take a
coke up video because I'm excited by
that okay so just to dampen your
excitement a little bit unfortunately
our conclusion of conclusion is that we
cannot ship this in 12:1 except in a
limited way and the reason is we cannot
ship a video player that's any way that
that anybody could be happy with um and
that's about it what about for extra I
mean what about if you just view the
video externally what do you mean by
that well I mean you're saying an in
notebook video player right it means
that we can't have an object video ok
well unless unless assume that messes up
the whole workflow if we can't have that
um well it was a mission
we haven't a sound object or an audio
object which has a play button in it but
it doesn't you know you could still
carry around the audio object without
being able to play it right in place and
it's kind of disappointing which you
could certainly carry it around without
her without being able to play it by
making sense yeah I mean the other thing
I'd point out you know you could as a
hack you know play it in a separate
window I mean I admit that's kind of
like 30 years ago but but still it is a
possible thing to do thing is that we we
believe we are gonna be able to have an
in notebook player once frontend has
support for library link and we can just
read frames through library like in the
front end to play okay well look it to
me it is not a hard percent obviously I
mean it's very cool to be able to have
an in notebook on desktop video player
okay however I still think video
manipulation absinthe
with the video being played either in a
pop-up or in a so very light away it
will be very limited video manipulation
in this release so the big bulk of it
this import/export stack those are it's
this huge set of work there yeah
well that's important I mean like for
example being able to take a manipulator
and animate and you know but that's not
there that's what I'm saying death that
kind of thing will not unlikely to be
there probably well okay but but okay
how about a list of images yes or export
yeah will be so that that will be
supported that's already supported it oh
okay so right now the only thing we can
do is an animated gif right in prototype
fields you can import all of those
formats that are listed on there import
will export and export to that well its
prototype so there may be some things
failing okay among the other things that
I might want to do is export a list of
images list yeah limit list of image
frames to an mp4 for example and you're
saying that that as of now that now
works yes okay
okay and I can do that even without the
video wrapper definitely okay um okay so
the
filter apply function to partitions of
video and audio data okay so what is
that is that a space-time filter so to
speak or what is that the video filter
thing
video filter the way it's it's not fully
baked but the way we have seen it is
that you can specify separate filters
for video or audio track and it could be
a single frame filtering or it could
take multiple image frames and then a
buffer of the audio and then so to me
the kind of thing that will be exciting
with video is saying you know annotate
which frames had a tiger in them show me
the time series give it your video comes
in what comes out is the time series of
tiger appearances in the video right
okay so which function here would be
able to do that I guess video video
block map is gonna be the thing that
could do that because video filter is
supposed to be video in video out
something like video block map is gonna
be video in measurements out okay so if
I say video block map of something baby
really what I'm trying to do is I'm
trying to get a true or false
is there a tiger or maybe how many
Tigers is it this is the thing I pasted
in chat is one version 12 product
example that we put together which is
using image contains cue to say whether
a dog is in there in each frame so
that's the time series version that's
the highlighted version so the this
safely says that's the time in the video
and you can play the video you just
click on that first frame that is shown
on top of the marketing page this was
already Aslam okay alright but as you
see we are in this example we are
reading frame by frame from the video
and then running image and since cue
what you're saying is that what or what
I'm saying is that video block map is
going to be the thing that is going to
be able to take image instance Q as a
function that gets wrong on every frame
or it could be a series of frames from
the video object and then require I mean
I think the obvious thing is a video map
that just computes for every frame in
the video something but a very common
thing and I don't know how this works
with with audio either is the interplay
between the time series mechanism and uh
you know and what you're observing in
the video or the audio because I mean
this is kind of messy right I mean the
fact you've got to do a list plot with a
bool and weird nonsense like that right
well image contains cue returns a
true/false so we had to do that yeah
right but I mean ultimately that will be
a time series whose values are true and
false probably right right
which who knows whether that happened
you know gets handled well or not or
could be anything else it could be some
mean intensity or could it could be some
position of the dog which I think we
have it as well further down in this
example and so forth but you're right we
see see that red line is a time series
of position of the image what image
position finds as a center position of
that dog right right um okay
okay so I mean the typical type of thing
look somebody's gonna want okay so we've
got image position I kind of think
people are gonna want video position
just like that okay let me speculate
just like we've got image cases image
position image count what is the analog
of that for a video does each of those
go time series video yeah maybe
oh there are as you said there there is
this spatial domain that we should think
about and then there is that temporal
domain Oh video so the a whole bunch
things like audio interval the analog of
that is going to be video interval
I understand but I mean so to me there
are two things you might want returned
you know like probably more so I mean
like in an in an audio for example you
might say you know I don't know and some
in some situation you know was there a
gun shot in this audio type thing you
know how many were there right and it's
just like for the whole audio and but
you also might want to know you know
what were the positions of you know how
often did I coughed Erick
meeting or something you know give me
the give me those times um oh yeah
another piece of personal analytics um
the the kind of interesting to track how
one's you know I'm just getting over a
coffee would be interesting to track how
that goes with functional time anyway
separate problem um but um what am I
trying to say
I'm saying that um in that case what you
would want is the kind of video let's
see I mean that that is
essentially a video time series instead
of video position right just asking for
essentially video time series where
you're saying you know image position
gives you a bounding box and so on in an
image right so I'm claiming the analog
of that is video time series which gives
you a time series about of something
it's a little obscure because there
isn't really a coordinate I mean the
coordinate is time in the video correct
and it's time relative to the beginning
of the video and I assume that we have a
way of saying the absolute moment you
know this video occurred on January 1st
you know 2020 21 or something something
stored in a metadata and yes originating
their starting time is one of those okay
so people would just be relative to the
beginning of the video just like what do
we do with the audio for absolute times
of audio do we have that mechanism there
as well there is also creation data and
time but no we have never come across
any application that wanted to make use
of absolute time of someone you
recording I think that would be useful
to have I think it'll be quite useful um
I can imagine all kinds of applications
particularly with video where people
care about you know security videos and
stuff like this um but there's a
question of how it's stored is it
something that's is that there is a that
piece in metadata and I think that
metadata can exist for audio as well
right okay also I think GoPro I proposed
this extended eggs if type metadata that
stores a lot of things including say GPS
location pair time for a video that is
taken is that what is the typical exit
for a video is that one yeah it's still
good the general metadata the general
exit for video that is stored as a whole
is very similar to the audio the the
image ones but how can I mean like like
if you have a zoom lens in your zoom
how can the focal length be fixed again
as I said there are not that many
devices that store properties of that
sort over time there's written proposals
I think the GoPro one is the only one
that I've seen well documented not that
I have dived into it yet fully alright
but anyway to me we should be looking at
things like video time series that are
the analog of video you know image
position more so I think things like
video filter video block map a lower
level constructs ok I guess the idea
behind video block map is very similar
to what you're calling video time series
well yes and no I mean it's got some
function come let's see there are
questions on this live stream by the way
we should point out for people
interested in a pre-release program that
if you are an official user you can
request access to pre-release program
through tech support um ok brian is
asking what video formats will be
supported by the in notebook player I
assume all reasonable formats once we
have a new notebook player is that
correct as far as containers the ones
that are listed on the notebook mp4
manouschka all QuickTime avai are going
to be documented formats and there are
more containers that are as well going
to be supported but there are less
popular so for the part time being we're
just documenting them on their video
format and then the dollar value
variables listed at the end of this
section the other video decoder is video
encoders are going to be all the support
that decoder encoders on the platform
that the my Mac pile is running ok
but so the issue I mean don't these
things have boatloads of different
codecs and so on yes call up dollar
video encoders and where you don't have
you don't ya if you have a prototype
those running let's see if it crashes
video encoders yep so those are the ones
that we can write or export to okay for
each one of those containers that are
here presented as keys like avrt there
are a whole bunch of codecs that we can
use to create AV ice and this is the
supported list so the first in each list
is that codec the second part by the way
should we consider using entities to
represent all this stuff rather than
just these are these strings or are
these like random what the heck are
these things as I said the pair's are
names and descriptions which I'm not
sure in fact we need the descriptions
perhaps just their names would be
sufficient but well if we have noise
entities then then you could always
query for the description let me think
what kind of properties might be
interesting other than the description
if you have anything useful to store but
like does anyone care when they were
proposed developed who's the maintained
there and things like that those are
really the main type of things harmless
to have that in there I mean it's some
it gives you if you're trying to date a
video and you know that this format
didn't exist until such-and-such a time
it might help you but okay so will there
be an optimized path for transcoding
videos um I think we have
one amino will be naturally one called
file convert which in the way we build
it here that can be optimized it
obviously doesn't pull it into the
kernel and things like that right that's
gonna be the first out of course so
Brian says it'd be cool to use system
modeler to create an audio or video
pipeline using drag-and-drop that's not
gonna fit the general technology of
having drag-and-drop interfaces we are
exploring in several different
directions sure um let's see Holly
emerges and tracking multiple items in a
video such as moving cells yes so giving
the indices of the frames where the
objects were present how can we offload
the image or video processing or object
detection to a GPU or TPU hopefully we
will be doing that hopefully our our for
example a neural network image detection
stuff object detection stuff will
automatically do that is that a true
statement yes but I'm not sure how fast
it's gonna be for video if if you're
sending frame by frame stuff to GPU
their overhead at that point might
already be very high well I mean so that
raises the question which is I think you
know not an immediate question of
whether we can sort of you know whether
we can essentially pipeline the setting
sending of large streams of video to a
GPU I don't know how it works and
clearly clearly people have solved that
problem I mean that's a that is a
standard and video demo of today so to
speak right there's a video stream and I
don't know how that feeds into the GPU
and how it you know how it some streams
through registers the GPU and so on um
okay so Ali is saying the index of a
frame plus the bounding box should be
sufficient to specify where something is
the index the frame is temporal bounding
box is spatial so in a sense what you're
saying is I mean one could imagine a
video position
in which I mean in a 3d image right
we're already giving voxel positions
with three coordinates correct yes so
the issue here and this reminds me a
little bit of the geo path story where
you know we have been giving positions
you know on the and I mean somehow this
has to dovetail with that you know we've
been given a position on the earth but
now we can have some position that moves
with time right
um so similarly here in a sense what you
need is some kind of video position
which contains both the you know we can
even plan for the future and imagine 3d
videos plus time so to speak I still
think the immediate storage for us is
gonna be a time series with a single X Y
or a rectangle or anything else stored
in it for the times that we have they
thought of interest well so what you're
saying is it's time on the outside yes
and then it's whatever it would be you
know whatever the return value from
image position for the single frame
would be that is the thing or whether
it's image position or something else
are they so this in a sense what you're
describing is a is a sort of video map
time series or something which takes
some function that is to be applied to
every frame and returns the time series
of the result of doing that I mean or
perhaps you want the same thing frame by
frame I don't really know I mean the
frames you know is it the case that most
videos that one sees in the wild these
days I should know this are they 60
frames a second - what are they a lot of
a lot of 60 frames per second is coming
now what is the fraction out there in
the market there's there a lot of lower
what is it what is it right now what is
the typical frame rate 15 or something
or what is it
no it's 25 or 30 okay I don't know I
lost track of this sorry I don't I don't
look up their frame rates for these
things no but I mean the standard movie
formats to come in you know yeah
frames a second right okay I guess but I
really think the new standard is
becoming sixty okay
fine but but but anyway so there's a
there's a meaningful you know the number
of frames in a video is certainly if we
returned a result to frame by frame as a
list that would not be a totally crazy
thing to do like in other words if we
returned the you know position of fishes
in in the UH in the image and we return
that frame by frame right and we simply
return a list of the fish positions for
every image then we should be able to
use now it's a little bit tricky because
imagine that case okay we've got a list
of fish positions there were five fishes
and then one of them swam out of the
frame and then another thing etcetera
etcetera etcetera so what we would have
is a list of you know bounding of a
differing numbers of bounding box
information different numbers amounts of
bounding box information and that's not
a format that we readily deal with in
for example um you know any of our list
plot stuff and so on so it's it's a
slightly complicated thing right if we
have variable numbers of objects as a
function of time any of our current
memory of our other functions don't
readily deal with that none of them well
the other thing is that for audio when
we return a time series we assume times
are absolute or relative times to the
beginning of audio it may end up being
more accurate more correct to have a
frame number as the indicator or the
timestamp rather than the time itself
right I guess it's in particularly when
you're mapping the video and the audio
together but Bill I mean so this is a
separate sort of higher-order issue is
we're going to end up returning things
that are variable length you know we're
going to have a time series that is a
different kind of time series than we've
had before it's a it's a kind of
I don't know a time features series or
something where at every time there's a
list of things that are I think if you
don't want to do anything with a time
series that's not a problem I see you
know so really I think that that's what
should have been the definition of it
it's a different discussion but that's
what should have been the definition of
of event series
there's no been Oh operations done it's
just a point in time that matters
the other things are basically
properties or annotations in which K
that's a different thing but it's still
it's still we need a whole gaggle of
functions that for example you know take
my example of the fishes okay now I want
you're not you know the algebra of
operating on earth as I said for time
series it's assumed to be a vector space
and that's what all filters everything
assumes that you can do if it started
back to space you have no corrosion so
look Roger even plotting where the
fishes were um yeah yeah but but but the
other big advantage of time series is
that you can operate on him if things
work and if you can't operate you know
you can't can't even define operations
right so early on our live stream is
suggesting using data set I mean this
this whole business about tracking
objects yeah I mean Ethan is saying
tracking multiple deforming object
through occlusion has supported better
in MATLAB at the moment I have no idea
what I mean I don't know I mean I don't
know what the the question is what is
the output right because you know you've
got a bunch of fish swimming around and
if we could take the fish named Jane and
the fish named John and you know we
could identify this you know the life
story of this particular fish maybe that
would be an example of something very
useful to get out that is um the the
sort of the the invert and not inverse
the there's some kind of pivot on the
you know
so one thing is frame-by-frame what fish
were in the frame and where were they
thing number two given a fish where was
it in what frames did exist the
transpose effectively hmm right so given
an object and I mean that is certainly
something I mean to me that is a that
would be a very useful thing for many
purposes given you know generate a
report in this video what objects did
you see and when and where did you see
them right which is a different thing
from saying in this video tell me what
happened
frame by frame now what's the amount
analog of that I mean the analog of that
is probably you know given for example
with faces given a an image you know
tell me what faces are in it and then we
do not currently have because we haven't
yet had to worry about for example faces
as a function of time but we haven't had
to ok what I mean is we don't have
essentially face centered to make a
silly pun versions of of analyzing in a
video or an image
what we have is image centered it's
given the image what faces were in the
image not given this face what images
was this face in that makes sense right
um I mean that relates another thing to
to work with image collections because
there's a lot of things that don't
necessarily put out video but put out
big image collections they're just right
and what's the relationship between what
we're doing here and what we're planning
with the whole you know the MongoDB
store stuff that we've been using
internally for a long time for dealing
with things like large image collections
have you have you explored that video I
guess and a large image collection I
don't see it
storing a video I think a video store it
should be a separate thing on its own a
separate type of data store well the
only thing is that I can't imagine a
situation in which you want to sort of
explode
video into a large collection of frames
sir
in which case you are gonna want some
kind of you know put it out into
something like this MongoDB store I
don't know whether the inverse of taking
the MongoDB store making an image out of
it is of interest I mean that's like
like I have that forum my crazy personal
ethics of screen capture my screen every
whatever it is 15 seconds or something
you know that can be assembled into an
unbelievably boring video um and I
suppose that's going from individual
frames to a video but I think that's an
uncommon case um the um yeah I sander is
commenting that tracking is a
complicated thing by itself absolutely
but that's exactly why we would love to
have a super function that does a
reasonable job of tracking um and yes
you need to pose the orientation right
um of the object and you know yes you
could need all kinds of but I mean the
ultimate look I mean the ultimate thing
that will be super cool for example is
there's a whole cluster of functionality
here I mean so for example deriving the
angle path representation of the fish
for example you know in other words what
was the you know given this object
it was swimming around and it made
certain intrinsic movements in the video
you know represented in terms of those
intrinsic movements but we don't have
that we don't have that mechanism right
now I mean given a given up a walk so to
speak representing it in terms of moves
made intrinsically in the walk we don't
have um yeah I mean this is a whole new
world of stuff to to analyze um I know
you know that um okay I think
switch I in about 30 minutes we're going
to a discussion about biomolecules that
we can't be late for I'm so we have two
choices Roger we can either continue
with this for the next half hour and
move the calculus and algebra to a
different time or we could take a quick
look at calculus and algebra I think we
continue with this and move calculus and
algebra okay fine fine okay um okay all
right well then let's take a quick look
ahead here um okay
now supports what is large wave files is
just you mean just like big big big like
hundreds of megabytes or something gates
okay or makes right okay SS ml what do
you need I mean unlike notes and things
for sound notes where you can give
styling information what is the
analogous so so we already talked about
a little bit if I want to say it's a
speaking stylistic analog
right but so what is the what is the
rich text version if I say I am very
upset or whatever so this is a thing
that we found there's one more this is
it this is this is what there's there's
one more except for SS ml what was that
shot II know but I'm asking what is that
symbolic representation of tagged speech
so that would be speaking style nested
speaking styles okay so no it's if I
want to tag my speech so I just want to
see consistency in several things okay
so you know we have this notion of text
elements right that's what if I were to
do a you know let's say for example I
want to go um a good example
don't take that sentence there and I say
tech structure of that sentence right
I'm just gonna I'm trying to show the
the different forms of textual
annotation we've got several things
running around and I think I need to
make sure that they are consistent
okay so here's this so now if we look at
the input form of this so notice the way
that this is displayed which already is
interesting because you can imagine
something in which you're displayed
voice styling thing actually has a
little underline that says you know
emphasized or whatever it is right hmm
but if we look at the input form here
this is a bunch of nested text elements
okay so what I'm asking is what is the
relationship between I mean is it is it
self-evident that we should not use text
elements with different property
annotations to represent these to
represent these speaking styles because
I mean this is already a thing that can
be wrapped inside well would things like
pause or I I see that some qualifiers
like this is a ward sentence paragraph
is shared between speaking styles and
tear on but I think I think design wise
okay so we've got several of these
things I mean we've also got the way the
XML wrappers work and what does text
cases do text cases has a way of
returning something which is a pre
annotated which is an annotated thing
right and similarly when okay let me
just understand something so audio it
has annotation rules and those are those
are kind of dead reckoning annotation
rules is that correct as in they go in
they are not they go in and they say for
this position to this position do this
it's that right they're not they don't
say do something they they have to
understand but what they're not
they're not wound inside the audio right
there from the outside they're saying at
this position of the audio this is the
annotation correct right whereas text
element is is sort of in twining itself
into the innards of the object right
right
um so my question here I'm I think that
this is the problem with both image
video and audio you cannot you cannot
Swami
yeah you can't entwine it well certainly
the two-dimensional thing in twining
would become very difficult okay so what
is the okay highlighted snippet how does
that work um let's see so I were to do
this and I were to say herro and by the
way this is another missing um
autocomplete and that is for Elizabeth
again here okay
look at that curious object now what is
that
you
that's just bonkers what the heck is
that
that's exactly raw raw typeset form I
don't even know what it means I know
what it's done here okay this is a
complaint for Elizabeth's needs to take
to Jerome and a TN I don't know what
this is um okay but that's got the same
type of issue that we have in the
speaking style thing I think I claim
because you know for example it's got to
be easy to take something with styling
speaking styling and just get rid of the
styling it's also got to be easy to take
something which doesn't have styling and
say every time you see the word um I
don't know I'm trying to think of some
some cute pop-culture reference of you
know every time you see such and such a
word sing it or something right um
but every time you see the word very uh
you know emphasize it or whatever else
it might take more than than this type
of light coordination that you're trying
to do now in order to get that level of
uniformity my nose I think we're gonna
need a meeting to talk about text
annotation and text and speaking
annotation okay
so it's got to bring together audio text
cases and you know voice synthesis
speech synthesis um I don't think this
is going to be that horrifying but I
think we just need to get it right and
we may need converters to go from from
between different forms all right let's
just take a quick look at your
import/export story here DICOM now this
is a big deal oh I haven't had I haven't
had any any um CT scans mris anything
like that for a while so I but I'm sure
I have some old data so so is it we have
like 400 standard metadata properties
so it's more a metadata story than it is
an image story but is the metadata like
this is the top of the kidney or
something or what what is it charlie
details of their metadata workflows for
radiologists
yeah I understand I'm asking how does it
okay so one question is does it align
with our Anatomy data for example is it
is it Anatomy specific I mean is there
it's part of that metadata specific to
kidneys and hearts and you know the
spine discs and things or or is it or is
it you can annotate calm with generally
graphics like this and lines then
circles and then give it some coordinate
systems but I don't think I don't think
I've seen so far I wouldn't be surprised
if there are samples out there that map
an image DICOM image to the human body
saying this is this well we know that's
a hard problem I mean people have done
that for very specific organs they've
done this kind of you know is this a you
know and they do it for for you know for
fetuses and things like that I think
yeah more than that the thing we have
seen especially with dark pom beers it's
about patient where the hospital was
when they study if this study had been
repeated when and how many times and
what girded right so it's it's a piece
of EHR that's been stuffed into the into
the dye kind because they exact because
the radiologists are worried that
otherwise it's gonna get lost
yeah and then okay all right fine so
it's not annotation of the daikon
content its meta annotation do you
typically annotate you know a segment
and say here is something and then who
did it and when okay all right but I'm
I'm guessing if I know how the world
works enough that the reason that stuff
is right in the image is because the
radiologists are rightly suspicious that
people will lose the rest of the record
yeah but I think that that's that's
generally a case like if when the
annotations get separated from the data
that header is very hard you know
um fair enough okay but but so what are
we gonna do how much are we going to
canonicalize mean it's like XF
canonicalization how much are we going
to try and canonicalize the the content
of the metadata for DICOM they're very
obvious things like when and where and
things like that that then can get
mapped to dates times GPS locations and
so forth cool it's a very flexible
beyond the I think 4000 is it that is
documented in this spec one can store
anything costs I mean fine but I guess
my question would be are we actually
gonna try and align to some of our
anatomical structures and things like
that or is that just not something that
DICOM already deals with I mean the very
interesting problem that people look at
from time to time is you know given a
standardized human you know can one
actually find given a radiological
imagery come on align that to the
standardized human so to speak and
thereby deduce you know if you've issues
taking a thing of a hand or something
can you readily annotate every single
bone in it and every whatever that's
that's very interesting I think the
modalities are gonna be messy a little
bit whether it's an MRI or CT and how we
aligned with the kind of data that's
beyond the state of the art to be able
to do that I mean that's something that
one hopes to be able to do and then then
you know then we'll all know you know
everybody has all kinds of anatomical
you know anomalies right because the
number of this you know number of
branches of this vein is never quite the
same for everybody and so on and so
everybody will be able to have kind of
the symbolic version of their anatomical
you know um features so to speak because
the you know the canonical human like
the one that we have in our Anatomy data
has just you know has just standard or
whatever the standard thing is you know
um okay one be
therefore dicom is also that you store
for 3d scans and things there's certain
layout directory structure and which
will now automatically recognize and you
will get them as volumes what is hei f
so we'll send you image format that
Apple first adopted this is more
compressed than JPEG with a higher quiet
quality Apple adopted it it's creating a
gif since a couple of years ago Windows
adopted that it's not yet as completely
know is it a wavelet based thing or was
it something completely different
what's it what's its compression
methodology actually out two questions
how do you say the word and what is its
compression technology I think it's hey
and it's a very comfort of discussions
whether it should be that the format's
name whether it's safe or Haake hei c
which is the codec itself it's a it's
still a very confused format concept out
there but it's being adopted because
they said it's half it's roughly half
the size with better quality but how
does it work do you know r le okay
that's good i mean at some point and
this is probably not for your team but
we should get somebody to do a proper
import/export for all features of galway
which includes macro cells for cellular
automata um
dct discrete cosine transform okay same
as same as all the other ones yes well
how can there be new how can there be a
factor of two to be gotten out of DCT I
don't know okay interesting
all right ah create archive um okay yeah
by the way um trying it maybe it's
because of image sequences that they get
the higher efficiency it's really aimed
for image sequences I see um okay Brian
is commenting there should be a way to
automatically convert from text emphasis
and stress eg caps bold italics to prose
ID for speech synthesis yeah be good
function to have I mean I think I think
generally you know pros OD rules to
determine from a given piece of text you
know what the emphasis should be is an
interesting thing is an interesting area
to explore I think so too I think that
as of right now the only synthesizers we
have that can accept that or external
whether we looked at that that's a bit
of a downer for it and they're all
varying support for this it's not right
particularly uniform unfortunately you
know we have some very interesting video
synthesis applications coming in Wolfram
Alpha which we could talk about
separately some at some point for which
we will care about a lot of the stuff um
okay
question for shadi from ali here is
there any idea of bringing virtual stack
to Mathematica to view
microscopic images sort Fiji image J
okay that's definitely not something I
know it so to Sharlee know the answer to
that I don't know what he means by
marital stuff okay well we should play
look up what image J is for example even
with limited RAM one can open up quite
large image stacks with virtual stacks
so it's some out of core processing
mechanism we have thought about that out
of core image processing for a while
it's just gonna be a very huge project
that was never justified whether we
really need it or what percentage of our
users are going to care for still it
doesn't seem like an individual image
can go well beyond our storage space
around space
I know there are applications out there
but it seems like working with a
collection of images is a more typical
task that we should tackle as a next big
project rather than trying to handle a
single very big image regular size
images out there but really applications
of them is still fairly limited
mathematical musings that handle notes
that with all the time we spend SIA she
spends watching these videos they could
have made their own Mathematica well
right no it takes much longer trust me
this this is the the ratio of time spent
discussing features here to time spent
implementing features is microscopic um
oh yeah um this is this could be my
theory of building software it's it's
you specifies and then it's done um but
anyway uh okay um okay Ethan is saying
that the way - ounce correctly works is
encoding multiple layers of information
as deeper image channels than JPEG at
twice the compression I see I see
interesting um and if there's also
commenting that many many people have um
what is its what is it some
file extension Apple stories at as Haake
hei see why haven't I seen this am i
just clueless or why wouldn't I have
seen this at some point maybe it's
because I read things enter enter
Wolfram language and then I just get
them as imagism and I don't see what the
format was fair enough but so when I'm
dragging something from somewhere like
from the Photos app on the Mac why isn't
it dragging in this format if it was
being taken in this format how do I
success drag and drop usually offers
number of difference
different formats right that's it so
there's a protocol so then what's
happening there because you know if I
drag and drop it works just dragging it
into a notebook but do you know what
it's dragging it as or how that works
it's it's the same format that is
storing it if there is a setting on your
phone that you can say whether you want
to save things and then share things as
high-efficiency format or as JPEG oh
I've seen this high efficiency thing
yeah okay fair enough that's the H E is
high efficiency okay now it makes some
sense to me okay um let's see Bryan is
saying image stacking is also he's an
astronomy Ethan is also encouraging us
to look at this Fiji thing which and how
he is saying that he plays with 200 gigs
right image stacks um and people in
microscopy apparently view several
gigabytes sized image stacks okay on an
image stack it's presumably what
different focal different depths or
something or what is that I don't know
if that's the only use there also yeah
okay all right let's just just scan
ahead here just for a moment
um Association support okay oh we're
getting protobuf yeah I know we is
protobuf coming out of your team or
somewhere else shadi it's it's it's
gonna be coming out of our team I told
you on Thursday priority at this point
is to make sure through the path needed
for Onix is bug free and as fast that it
has to be whether the association
support makes it into twelve one or no
at this point I don't think it's that
important because that was for multi
file formats and onyx is a single file
yeah that's fine
oh I see that the Association for multi
file okay so that gives the name of the
file so just so I understand that
Association agrees with the file system
scan Association structure correct
I'm not sure well this association
support is gonna say that I have I would
like to import something that has piece
of its information saved in one file and
another piece of it and a difference I
understand look at what file system map
does okay so file system map gives you a
right so it's showing this payload for
each of a succession of files right
named files okay and so what I'm
understanding is that in your case what
you would be saying is import a
collection of files import I see I see
what you're doing is you're saying this
place this feature of the format is
coming from this file this feature of
the void is coming from that file yes so
it's kind of a transpose of what's going
on here correct yes but in a in a multi
file I'm a little confused here
I mean so see with protobufs you specify
a structure in one file and actual data
given in that structure isn't another
file that that's the idea with without
one the other one doesn't make sense and
cannot be imported say into MX net or
something like that so that's where you
want to say my JSON is this file my
params is that file take that makes that
case right right okay fair enough so
it's not quite the same I mean we need
to understand yeah we need to understand
how that relates to file system rabbit
seams because particularly when it comes
when file system app is dealing with
nested directories it has all kinds of
stuff going on here right so you see
that directory structure represented in
the Association so if we do have a
directory I guess we don't in this case
because what all you're saying in this
case is it's this feature of the format
is to be
in the Spile talk where um um okay okay
good I think you may care about what we
have done with cellular automaton for
already we may want to have a separate
quick meeting about that but if you want
to open orally at this point or maybe I
can just explain yeah you're introducing
a cellular automaton element to orally
that is that is giving an inactive
cellular automaton because cellular
automaton evaluates and I think what we
care is there you know we can access the
rule number and the initial state
separately is that's a bad way to do it
I think we should do we should bring
back the Association form of cellular
automaton which contains all of that
information and then you should be able
to I think it can contain everything
there um hold on don't do not generate
an inactivated cellular automaton
function I think that's a balk yeah um
and however I think if I remember
correctly that we set it up so that
celery Taunton and if it hasn't been
done this way it certainly could be done
this way um has rules
vacation by an association so what it
doesn't have only is the initial
condition correct no I don't see that
syntax there is no association of the
format rule goes to this and it shall
stay it goes to that well we should
consider that probably okay requires a
separate meeting because otherwise I am
NOT a big fan of bringing back a you
know it's actually kind of crazy because
you bring back a cellular automaton
function with its two first arguments
filled in and its third argument missing
and how do you add the third argument
and I don't think it curries that way
either it doesn't okay so that's a bad
idea
um and um okay um we have to go for
those interests in live stream we are
about to have one about biomolecules
which includes some outside experts as
well um and yeah um okay so we're gonna
need to come back and look at this some
more Roger and shadi but um
clearly made some good progress here
okay and thank you to everybody thanks
to folks on the livestream lots of good
comments
all right see y'all soon